all right Louis we have a couple very
very compelling pictures from my
Instagram feed over the last week of
course I'm on Instagram it david pakman
things are getting pretty crazy on my
Instagram feed I know you're you're
you've attested to this uh have I i yes
yes right about Leah uh breakfast
pictures seem to do really well and the
other day I actually I I don't often do
this but I took a picture of my
breakfast which I will show you here um
and it's I it's not that often that I
just have a good old-fashioned breakfast
you know got no no this was at the a
place called the paramount in Boston
which I highly highly recommend uh are
you still in to breakfast these days
like you know pancakes or home fries and
eggs like the traditional American
breakfast I don't like getting up and
going out for breakfast yeah I just uh
but uh I love the food the breakfast
food I love it there's some great brunch
place right across the street for me
shore and it's great i love pancakes and
french toast and all that stuff is
terrible for you you into that world
Jason as far as like you know the the
stereotypical big American breakfast I'd
say my favorite breakfast ever is a
breakfast frittata like you know quiche
without the crust that's right you know
my go-to but I don't know not so much a
pancakes and waffles guy more uh eggs in
potatoes kinda guy blood sausage anybody
uh now Matt yeah no I don't eat pork
anymore but when I was a little kid I
used to love blood sausage till I
figured out what it was and then uh I
loved it a little bit less and then you
know now stood out now I just faced it
out yeah also this is the most popular
picture on my Instagram feed over the
last week if you're looking at this and
if you're not you can pull up my account
on instagram at david dot pakman i went
to a place in salem massachusetts
infamous for the Salem witch trials of
course there's a place called bit bar
which has a whole bunch of console
arcade games and I played what was
growing up one of my favorite arcade
games not console arcade games the big
it would what am I talking about arcade
game arcade games another console right
and played NBA jam and i love this game
when I was a kid it was the best you
know you had the codes to get players
with the huge heads and just such a such
a fun game
I really love that one and people for
whatever reason people seem to think
it's hilarious when I am playing video
games I don't know why I've said every
once in a while I will play a video game
yeah Dave plays games now and then and
uh he likes the old school games who
doesn't yeah NBA jam was yeah when we
were kids on man classic the whole the
term he's on fire I came about yes from
NBA jam I also played Mortal Kombat to
disaster lost in the first round and
what what's the shooting game virtual
copper to a cop which it has like these
polygons like graphics that are so dated
but the gameplay still holds up I have
to tell you that is my favorite arcade
shooter of all time virtual cop one and
two so remember that you can follow me
on instagram at david dot packman up a
lot of those pictures are only on
instagram they're not on our twitter
page they're not on our facebook page
cetera and remember they're still a
membership discount code that i posted
to my Instagram account it's about 8
posts back and uh it's a discount code
if you want to sign up for membership